[Music]
here comes the bride
with a military guard a moment of levity
for one unit responsible for guarding
the capital kyiv
[Music]
the unit's part of the territory of
defense and is made up of volunteer
soldiers
war often reduces humans to basics water
food shelter survival
but this territorial defense unit is
celebrating the stuff that makes life
worth living
the proud couple hold their wedding gift
as they get their pictures taken
of course we are the happiest
we are a little stressed i didn't expect
so much attention
under ukrainian martial law the unit
commander can officiate a wedding
something he says he was honored to do
this is exactly why we are having the
ceremony we want to show the world that
life goes on despite the war people get
married they don't stop being happy they
don't stop smiling and they have
something to look forward to for the
future
it's an unusual start to married life
and one this couple will remember for a
long time
the ceremony however was brief lasting
just under 20 minutes and the unit is
straight back to duty there's no time
for a honeymoon or anything like that
the groom is actually going back to the
front lines and everybody else is going
back to their positions as well but it
just goes to show you even in wartime
love can blossom imran khan al jazeera
kiev